finance ministers meeting on Tuesday
we'll discuss the Commission's proposed
action plan on investment specifically a
proposal to establish European fund for
strategic investments the fund is one of
the core elements of the Commission's
investment plan for Europe it is
expected to mobilize at least three
hundred fifteen billion in private and
public investment across see you in
areas such as transport energy
infrastructure education health and
research conclusions should be adopted
on the Commission's animals growth
survey ministers are expected to call
for structural fiscal and monetary
policies designed to address issues such
as the risks of persistent slow growth
and high unemployment in member states
the council's conclusions also deal with
the Commission's alert mechanism report
the report points out how make reckon
ohmic imbalances whisk in during a
smooth functioning of the US economy and
monetary union a procedure to avoid such
imbalances is forcing in your areas
countries can be fine if they repeatedly
failed to follow the council's
recommendations ministers are also due
to set priorities for the you budget for
2016 and to adopt the recommendation on
the budget discharge for 2013 the
chairman of a high-level group unhone
resources will present a first
assessment report on the EU's financing
system